the apple watch series 8 lineup is
coming very soon likely within the next
two months and i think that is going to
be a game changer and awesome upgrade
with a brand new design especially if we
get the new series 8 pro model which i
think is what the rugged rumors are
leading to and i'm gonna explain why i
think that in this video alongside all
my other leaks and rumors that i'm gonna
discuss in this video including the
display size but before i get into those
new series 8 lineup leaks i want to
discuss the current apple watch lineup
so let's get started now currently we
have the brand new series 7 which has
the larger display compared to the old
series 6 with the new more rounded edges
and corners and that's definitely a
really nice display but it does start at
400 just like it did before we have the
apple watts se which has the same kind
of design and chip as the old series
five except that it does not have the
always on display that's exclusive to
the high-end series seven model and then
we have the series three which i think
should not even exist at this point it
has the old chip the old design look at
that the square display it does not look
good it's outdated it's only two hundred
dollars but i do not think that's a good
buy because you pay a little bit more
you get the se that's a much better buy
and the crazy thing is that apple's new
watch os software
it's going to be coming out this fall
and apparently it's not even going to
support the series 3 which basically
means that apple is going to be
discontinuing
this series 3 model and they're going to
be introducing a new model into the
lineup which mark german is saying is
the rugged edition but before i get into
explaining those leaks and rumors let's
start off with some of the other ones
now first of all over the past six
months i made a couple of videos talking
about the series a pro including this
one talking about the truth revealed and
this basically talked about how john
prosser thought that the series seven
was going to be getting the new flat
sides with the whole redesign
potentially a flat display but in this
video he mentioned that maybe he had his
leaks a little bit early so maybe all
those flat design
rumors are actually going to be coming
true with the series 8 model which i
believe is to be the case but with that
said let's jump into these rumors back
on july 3rd we had some rumors where the
apple watch series 8 might be able to
tell if you have a fever so there was a
chance that they could use these new
health tracking sensors potentially the
temperature tracking sensor to see if
you have a fever and basically give you
a warning let you know to get some water
get some rest which would be a really
really cool feature and then just the
other day mark german came out with an
awesome report saying that apple's gonna
have a rugged extreme sports watch
coming later this year with a larger
nearly two inch screen yes that's pretty
large and i'll explain what they mean by
that
non-aluminum metal case it's going to be
more shatter resistant in terms of the
screen and i'm going to explain why that
makes sense a larger battery of course
because it's going to have a larger
display body temperature sensor
improvements to hiking and swim tracking
and more and getting into the actual
display details we had a report from
ross young and jeff poo saying that the
new display is going to be around 5
larger now specifically it's 1.99
inches which sounds massive but
apparently the way that they're
measuring it is diagonal so that's how
the panel suppliers measure it so it's
not actually going to be the size of the
display itself which some people thought
it could be up to 50 millimeters but
that is not true apparently according to
the way that apple measures and markets
their display sizes joe resignal thinks
it might be around 46 or 47 millimeters
in size and shrimp apple pro actually
thinks it could be 47 millimeters for
just the display alone so that would
mean that you would have sizes of 43
millimeters and 47 millimeters for the
small size and the large size and i
personally think it actually makes sense
to have a 46 millimeter i don't know if
that's possible with this big 1.99
inch display size maybe it's gonna be
larger but i think it'll flow smoothly
because i'm personally expecting the
apple watch se2 to have the same display
size that's 40 millimeter and 44
for 279 dollars than the regular series
8 model which is 41 and 45 which is
matching the series 7 right now and the
price is going to stay the same 399 for
the aluminum model of course more if you
get the different finishes and i think
for the series 8 pro or the new rugged
edition model 42 and 46 so it's kind of
like incrementally stepping up higher
and higher i think that'll make sense
but for eight hundred dollars with a
titanium chassis as the standard option
or of course some kind of other alloy or
metal because shrimp apple pro is
actually saying that the new metal is
gonna be different from aluminum and it
could be some kind of liquid metal with
an alloy mixture i'm not sure what
exactly that means but i think titanium
would be a good choice because it is
more rugged while also being lightweight
but now i want to explain why this is
going to be a big deal and this new
apple watch series 8 pro model is going
to be very enticing first of all i think
that john prosser and ian's elbow were
correct about their rumored new design
with the flat sides and i think it could
end up looking something like this maybe
it's not going to be that large of a
flat side but generally something like
this and this is important because as
you can see the display is completely
flat now mark german was saying that
it's going to be a lot more rugged and
the screen will be more shatter
resistant well if you look at these
renders the actual display can be
completely flat now when you do this it
allows you to make the bezels thinner a
lot more easier like for example with
the iphone 12 just by going to the flat
design apple was able to make the bezels
a lot thinner than they were with the
iphone 11 because that rounded glass and
everything made it difficult to put in a
larger display underneath it so having a
completely flat panel will make it
easier to enlarge the display and thin
down those bezels even more which will
allow the actual chassis to not get that
massive when you're increasing the
actual display size but not only that
the actual metal lip is going to be
protruding out of the apple watch with
the display kind of tucked in which is
gonna make it a lot more durable because
if you accidentally smack something
you're smacking the outside metal shell
and frame instead of smacking the glass
like you have on the current apple watch
designs making it a lot more easy to
shatter so that would solve that issue
and now about six months ago when i made
this video about the series 8 pro leaks
i made a few predictions first of all i
had the 800 starting price coming with a
titanium chassis standard i have the
prediction of much better battery life
because if you're switching from rounded
glass and display underneath it to a
flat design you could actually move the
whole display panel with glass higher
making more internal space for
everything else including a larger
battery so much better battery life of
course since you're also making the
chassis a little bit larger as well and
max safe support new high-end sensors
which we could get with the temperature
sensor and of course the larger display
which i thought would be 46 millimeters
but i want to talk about the max 8
because mark german has been talking
about the future ipad pro coming with
wireless mac save support and he even
mentioned that we could be seeing apple
watch max safe charging support coming
in the future and i think if we do get a
larger series 8 pro with a flat design i
think it will support max save charging
and that'll be a huge feature for a lot
of people because i feel like apple is
going
full force into wireless max aid because
they've added it to the airpods they're
going to be adding it to the ipad pro as
far as the rumors are concerned and we
even got some patents of apple working
on adding wireless mac save chargers
built into the center console of the
apple car in the future so i think apple
is going full force into mac safe and i
believe it's going to be coming to the
apple watch as well specifically for
this larger model so with that said
because of these leaks even if you don't
go for the series 8 pro model or just
the regular series 8 i think it's a good
idea to hold off for another two months
before buying one of the current apple
watches because i believe the series se
model is going to be replaced with the
se2 i believe the series three is going
to get completely discontinued do not
buy that one and of course the series 8
is going to get some incremental updates
compared to the regular series 7 model
so if you disagree with me on anything
in this video let me know in the comment
section below but if you agree click the
circle but to subscribe and definitely
check out those two older videos i made
right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you